Hello, good morning.
I'm tired.
Good boy.
That's why I took a power nap.
It was a bad... Never take power naps, guys.
Never take power naps.
I fucked up.
I'm so tired.
You know, guys.
Oh my god.
Guys, okay.
I was like, okay, I had to get coffee or take a nap.
And I was like, no, I shouldn't.
I shouldn't depend on caffeine to stay awake.
Naps are always a cat scam.
I 100% agree with you, Nixie.
They are a scam.
They are illegal.
They shouldn't be a thing.
Anyway, I was like, okay, I had to take a...
Can I get a super chat?
Thank you.
Okay, I was like, okay.
Also, by the way, I just found out recently that like...
Okay, wait.
Let me look this up.
Let me look this up real quick.
I don't know if they were gaslighting.
Okay, so I recently found out that Frappuccinos is caffeine.
I recently found out about that because I was like, no, I don't like any.
I don't want to try to depend on caffeine, but I do like Frappuccinos.
And then one of my friends was like, you do know Frappuccino has caffeine in it?
I was like, what?
I thought it was just blended ice with like the flavors.
I thought it was just blended ice.
And then my friend was like, no, the base is caffeine.
And so I was like, why did my parents order me Frappuccino as a child?
I was like, wait, I drank Frappuccinos as a child.
I was like, I thought they were just giving me sugar drinks.
I thought it was just sugar.
So I was like, oh my God.
You beat me up with drinking caffeine since I was a kid.
My dad would order his Frappuccino and then he would give me a Frappuccino.
So then I'd be like, yippee, cream!
And like, yay!
Yippee, it's sugar drinks with no caffeine in it.
Because Frappuccino is just ice.
It's just blended ice with sugar and whatever flavor you decide to put on.
And yeah, no, my mom and dad was ordering Frappuccinos growing up.
And as I get older, I was like, no more Frappuccinos for me.
I'm a big girl now.
So big girls drink lattes.
And then after that, I'm like, sometimes I want to be a little girl and drink a Frappuccino that has no caffeine in it.
Because it's just blended ice and sugar.
It's so relatable.
Oh my god.
I like, that blew my mind.
That actually blew my mind.
I was like, so I'm like this?
I was just like, wait.
Okay, you're not supposed to give your child caffeine at a young age.
But...
You're not supposed to.
But clearly, this is what happens when your child has been growing up with caffeine, apparently, since she was young.
And I didn't even know.
I didn't even know.
So I've been hooked on caffeine since I was a child.
I can't believe it.
But I haven't been drinking a lot of caffeine.
I don't drink a lot of caffeine, though.
As I got older, I drank less.
No, that's a lie.
When I got out of university, I started to drink less and less caffeine.
That seems a little better.
My caffeine consumption did get lower when I got out of university.
No name!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Naps are not a scam if you go this strap.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I am average height for a tomato.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Many.
Inkslicer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you explains why you're so amped half the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Uh Mori, thank you for the super chat and then and I found out later on.
I swapped the green tea like the um What was it?
Green bottle uh Ito, ito something bottle green.
How is it called?
Uh ito yen.
I swapped the ito yen And then and I found out from you guys that that also had caffeine in it So i've been fucked i've been like actually fucked up for majority of my life.
Uh And then I found out that also had caffeine I've been non-stop drinking that and I found out from you guys that that also had caffeine in it And then I was like, oh fuck And so after that I went back to water Just water and I think maybe that's why i'm tired all the time I think I honestly think my body has been so used to like Caffeine for a majority of my fucking life apparently That's why sometimes I get really really tired So,
I'm fucking fine, and then my friend was like, are you fucking stupid?
Like, why would you think Frappuccinos had no caffeine in it?
I was like, because my parents kept ordering it for me!
Like, I thought when I was a child!
I don't know!
I just thought that, like, you wouldn't give your child caffeine!
So I just kept, and I see them make it, and then I see them make the Frappuccino, and like, you know, I just see them put ice!
And then I was like, wow!
It's just made of blended ice!
I thought that was just a drink for the children!
I thought they put that there for the kids!
And then I see them, you know, scoop the ice up, and then like, so I was like, that's what it's made out of!
Ice!
And sugar!
And...
I didn't realize that they put caffeine as a base!
No, I thought Frappuccinos...
I know, now that I say it, you guys are like, Doki, Frappuccino rhymes with cappuccino.
But I thought it was just cappuccino for kids!
That's where the kappa is gone!
Cause coffee starts with a C.
Cause coffee starts with a C, so that's where the kappa is from.
So they remove the kappa part, the caffeine part, and then they make the Frapp part.
So like, the Frappuccino stands for freedom.
I don't fucking know.
I just thought, because the kappa part is removed, that means there's no caffeine in it.
Cause that's where the Frapp means.
I don't fucking know.
It just never dawned to me that it has caffeine in it.
I just thought it just had a lot of sugar.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why Doki laughs like that.
It all makes sense now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it just means frozen.
Frozen ice.
Chino.
That's what Frappuccino said for me.
Frozen ice and then Chino.
I don't fucking know what the Chino is.
I don't know what the Chino is.
But it just made sense.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Rykro.
Rykro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It makes you feel better.
I had the same experience.
I never realized McDonald's frappes had...
Exactly!
Why the fuck would they make something that tastes so good and not be for kids?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And it tastes so good.
Why is it not made...
Why is it not made for children?
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't tell me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
Today, we're gonna be playing...
It might be a short stream because it's just a demo.
But if you ever...
Oh, by the way, I just found out that...
Friday Night Funkin' is actually releasing...
I think like this week, is it?
Friday...
The official release for it.
I just realized that.
The official release for Friday Night Funkin' is apparently...
Releasing...
Oh, not this month.
It's apparently releasing...
This month.
Is it a full game?
Or like the next update?
Oh, not full release.
Just a pit stop.
Oh, okay.
So never mind.
I pledged for this game.
I've been in the Kickstarter for this game for a while now.
So I don't even know what the next update...
So apparently, the next update will be...
This month.
I mean, that's something, you know?
Update of the mini-update.
Oh, it's just a mini-update.
Okay, never mind.
The next update is...
Destination update.
Okay.
So there's a lot of updates that they still have to do.
But hey, oh, the figures are coming out.
I don't even remember what I pledged for.
It's been so long that I don't even know what I pledged for.
It's...
So like...
So I have no idea where we're at anymore.
Anyway, so...
So...
A couple of dragoons made a mod.
A fan mod.
Of Friday Night Funkin'.
That's streamed around me and you guys.
So I'm excited to check it out.
It's called Tomato Funkin'.
Apparently it's just a demo.
But I still wanted to check it out.
Just because I love checking out the stuff you guys made.
And everything.
And...
And it's going to be pretty exciting.
I'm not too...
Some of you guys are like, oh yeah, the updates...
Updates take so long for it to come out.
And like...
I need you guys to remember it.
I know it's hard to fucking take Kickstarter seriously.
Especially for games and stuff.
But like...
I do trust in the Funkin' crew.
I don't fucking know who the creator was.
I do trust them.
Because they are still at least posting updates and stuff.
It's just...
Games do take a really fucking long ass time.
And I need you guys to remember...
Okay, if you guys don't remember...
Omari was a Kickstarter game.
And the thing is...
Before Omari came out...
There were tons of callout posts about the creator.
For like...
They were saying that...
They were never going to deliver the game.
I remember back then...
When...
Omari...
Before it actually came out...
And became a fucking...
Was it a bestseller or whatever the fuck?
I never played that game by the way.
Because it's not my cup of tea.
I'm not like...
I cannot play JRPGs.
I know it's not technically a JRPG.
But like...
It's geared towards...
It's the style of the game.
Omari?
I don't know how to pronounce it.
I never played it.
But like...
People were so fucking mad.
People were...
Incredibly mad.
About the game.
And the creator.
Because it took like...
How many years for it to come out?
People thought she was scamming them.
Because it never came...
It took so long...
For it to come out.
I remember there was like...
Twitlongers, callout tweets, callout posts.
And people were like...
She was refunding people and everything.
And then when the game came out...
It's like everyone forgot.
Sorry about fucking calling you out.
And thinking you're a scammer.
Great game!
Yeah.
There was so much drama.
I remember on Twitter.
There was like so much fucking drama.
About it.
Yeah.
And then the game came out.
And then nobody said anything after that.
So like...
I feel like...
That's why...
Like right now, I don't think...
Friday Night Funkin' is...
Scamming anybody.
Even though it does take...
It is taking a long time for the game to come out.
But...
But like...
To be fair...
Omori did take like 7 years.
So...
If it hits 7 years...
Then...
If it hits 8 years...
Then it might be pretty bad.
And then there were people who backed what was that game.
Mighty No.
9?
Oh, those guys definitely got scammed.
Yeah, that's definitely...
I want to play Mighty No.
9.
I forgot I had that on.
Actually, can I still buy Mighty No.
9?
I can still...
Oh my god!
Guys, next week I'm going to play Mighty No.
9.
Guys...
Is it...
Why is it not on Steam?
Oh wait, Steam sell ended.
Fuck, okay.
I should have bought it during the Steam sell.
I'm going to play Mighty No.
9 next week, guys.
I've played so many good Mega Man games.
It's time for me to play...
Mighty No.
9.
I don't...
For those who don't know Mighty No.
9, it was a kick-started game by...
Was it like the creators of Mega Man?
And all the team, people that used to work for Mega Man.
And they're like, we're going to make our own spiritual successor to Mega Man.
And it's going to be better than everything you've ever imagined.
And then they got like, how much money?
Okay, Mighty No.
9 kick-started.
And then they got...
$3,845,000.
Plus investors, too.
Plus investors.
Oh, the producers.
Okay, from the producers.
It's always like...
Okay, it's always sketchy when...
You know, all these big-name people out there couldn't get investors to invest in their game.
I always feel that's incredibly... Because if you're like really well-known producer slash producer or like creator out there, and you want to make like, you know, slash a spiritual successor or whatever, and you don't have like investors that want to invest in your game even though you have a big name for yourself in the community,
then like I feel like...
I feel like it's a little bit of a red flag to me.
Even Kojima couldn't get investors until...
Yeah, but he still got PlayStation in the end.
He still got PlayStation.
And also because like...
It's like hard.
It is pretty...
If you have a bad, like, you know...
I mean, Kojima got fired, so like a lot of companies were like...
They didn't want to touch him for a bit because they're like, oh shit.
So I relate.
Kojima...
Hikari, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It did take time, and then he got the investor.
Anyway, good to know on my birthday that Doki is a fellow coffee addict.
It was a non-consensual coffee addict.
I didn't even realize.
I was drinking caffeine the entire time.
Also, happy birthday, Hikari.
Happy birthday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Hikari.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
There is a game that I did want to check out from the Kickstarter that was from a couple of JP devs, but I did get a little worried because it was supposed to be a spiritual successor to a music game, but I don't remember what it was called.
But the music was so...
The music was like...
It's like you use music and beats to control the game, or whatever.
Is it Ratatat?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Ratatat.
That looked really interesting, but I also got a little worried because, like I said, if they can't get actual investors to help out with the game, and they rely on Kickstarter, I get worried about that.
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, so like, that worries me a lot, but it looks really good.
I love the music though.
The music sounds really, really good.
The visuals are really nice.
So...
Yeah, so I hope it's not another Mighty No.
9 situation.
I don't think I've seen a lot of games from JP developers that started in Japan that have blown up really well.
So that's why...
This is the one that I'm really looking forward to.
I feel like...
Yeah, it's such a wild card.
I'm just trying to think of a game that's from a JP dev that's done really well from Kickstarter, but I can't at the moment.
I know a lot of indie devs that made games from Kickstarter that did really well, but I can't think of one from JP devs.
Was it Bloodstained?
Bloodstained.
I don't know what Bloodstained is.
I know... What was it called?
Skullgirls tried to Kickstart another game, but it didn't do so well.
I don't remember what it was even called.
I've never heard of this one.
What the fuck is Bloodstained?
Is it supposed to be a Castlevania spiritual successor?
Oh, it's like Castlevania?
Did it do well?
Oh, it has 27,000?
I never heard of this one.
To be fair, I'm not a Castlevania player.
I never grew up with Castlevania.
I'm so sad that the new Castlevania anime...
The new Castlevania show on Netflix is so fucking bad.
That's so weird.
Yeah, I saw season two, the newest season of the...
There's a newest season, the newest spinoff.
The newest spinoff of the uh...
of the Castlevania show, and I didn't even watch the newest season.
I watched the first season of the new spinoff and it was alright.
And then the second I didn't even watch, but it wasn't great.
Like, it was alright.
Like, I was not like a big... I don't know.
I didn't really enjoy it that much.
And then I tried to watch season...
I tried to watch season two...
I tried to watch the first episode of season two, but I just wasn't feeling it.
I wasn't feeling the plot or the animation or story whatsoever, so I never finished it.
Which sucks, because I really liked the first series of the show.
Until like... I liked the first series of the show.
The only weirdest part was when... What's his name?
Was it Alucard?
Yeah, it was when Alucard got in a fucking threesome.
Like, out of nowhere.
And then murdered them.
Because they were trying to...
Like, that was...
That was...
Yeah, that was a little weird.
I thought that was out of nowhere.
When he got...
When he got into a fucking...
Oh, he did what?
Okay, so...
It's not really spoilers, because it doesn't really advance the plot whatsoever.
I'll have to say, it does not actually advance the plot whatsoever.
So, to just...
I don't know.
That part was so...
It just felt like...
It was just fanservice.
It felt like a filler fanservice thing, where he just suddenly decides he's like, let me fuck both of them, I guess.
And then they try to murder him, and then he's like, oh, fuck, okay.
Guess I'll kill them.
You ain't a vampire.
You wouldn't get it.
Yeah, so...
Yeah.
It just fell out of nowhere.
That's really it.
I just feel like... Also, yes, I did download the newest update, so don't worry.
I saw that you guys did the newest update, so I did see that, so don't worry.
I did download it, so no worries, guys.
Also, I was testing out the game, and I realized that...
When I was testing out the game, to make sure everything works, I'm really bad at... I keep forgetting that I'm incredibly terrible at rhythm games.
Every time...
Whoa!
That's me!
Every time I...
Every time I go and play rhythm games again, I am reminded of how fucking terrible I am at rhythm games.
Alright.
So, it's gonna take...
It's supposed to be a fast, fast, like, short game, but it could be really, really long, depending on if I can complete it or not.
So, yeah!
Huge shout-out to the devs for...
for making a fan mod for me.
It looks amazing so far as a demo, too.
Whoa, buy my merch.
Alright, so let's check out the credits, see who made it.
Alright, so...
Nice cock!
A huge shout-out to all the people that, uh, contributed and, um...
Yeah, that's me!
Contributed to this mod.
I am looking forward to, uh, checking...
What the fuck?
I'm looking forward...
I'm looking forward to trying it out, guys.
I feel like I should be smaller for this.
Give me a sec.
Let me be a little smaller.
I wanna be tiny.
I'm gonna be a tiny-mato.
Alright, let me adjust myself real fast.
Alright.
There we go.
I wanna be here.
Or do I wanna be here, or do I wanna be here?
Yeah, I wanna be here.
There we go.
I'll be standing here.
Maybe I should get my box.
Where's my box?
Ha ha ha!
I got lazy, so you guys are seeing that.
Oh, there's my box!
There we go.
Alright.
Now it feels natural.
I got my box, guys.
Sorry, you're gonna be unimmersed for a little bit.
I say as I try to...
Alright, there we go.
I'm on my box.
Alright.
I feel a little better.
Now that I'm on my box and I feel like an adequate height for all of you guys, I'm ready to play the game.
Ha ha ha!
I unimmersed you to be reimbursed.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
I need my little booster seat, guys.
Sorry.
Now I'll actually play the game.
Alright, story mode.
So, I've actually never played the original game, by the way.
All I've done is play the mods.
Ha ha ha!
I've played a ton of the mods, but I've never played the original game.
I've seen the videos of it.
I just never played it myself.
Alright.
Let's go with normal, because I don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself, so I'm gonna go with normal, because I know I'm...
Oh, that's you!
Oh, wait.
I'm on the right side.
I forgot I'm boyfriend.
I'm fighting myself.
Why is it so fast?!
Ha ha ha!
Shit!
This is normal!
Oh my God!
Okay.
Um...
Wait, this is normal?!
How is that normal?
Wait, that was a sound, by the way.
How is that normal?!
How the fuck is that normal difficulty?!
Oh my God!
Oh!
How the fuck?!
Let me... Guys!
Guys, I need a...
Guys, give me a sec.
I might need...
It's okay.
You can't see what difficulty...
I'm playing hard right now.
Guys.
Guys, I'm on hard.
See?
It's on hard, guys.
It's on hard.
Guys.
Guys, it's on... Guys, it's on hard.
It's on...
Guys, guys, it's on hard.
Guys.
Guys, it's on hard, guys.
I decided I need a bigger challenge.
I decided I need a bigger challenge, guys.
I...
Holy fuck!
Oh my God.
How did it get so easy?
I'm so good at it now.
Oh my God.
Wait, maybe I am a natural.
Oh my God, I'm a natural.
Oh my...
Look at me go!
Woo!
Who would've thought maybe a rhythm game is for me on hard?!
Oh
my God.
Oh my God.
Guys, it's on...
Guys, I would never lose an easy.
You know that.
I would never lose on easy, guys.
But I would absolutely lose at hard.
How do you...
How...
How?
How did I do this before when I played against Sans?
Wait, where do I use a controller?
Maybe I'm just better on controller, guys.
Okay, nice.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
Oh my God, please.
Oh my God, I'm so lagged in.
Please.
It's not that bad.
Guys, it's not that bad.
I still have a little HP left.
I'm still alive.
Don't look at the scum score.
Oh my God, where am I?
Where am I?
I'm alive.
Oh my God.
Lifeline!
Oh my God, thank God there was a lifeline.
Oh thank God, oh thank God, I lived by it.
Okay, look at that.
I lived!
I lived by the dot!
I'm alive!
Oh my God, I survived!
I survived!
See, guys?
I told you I am on hard difficulty too!
Wow!
Why is it not going to the next level?
Oh, is this one of the bugs?
Look at that.
Guys, look at that.
Guys, why is it not going to the game crash?
See, I did so well that my game just crashed, guys.
Look at that.
I did so well.
That's when the game knew that I was gaming, chat.
Does it sound better now?
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
Alright, so I...
How do I...
Wait, but how do I get to the heist part?
Can I free play this?
Wait, I didn't.
Do I have to name it?
Do I have to name my mod?
So it could work?
Wait, is that a thing?
Guys, I didn't know if that's a thing.
Wait, can I just play... I'll just play this.
I think heist is broken.
Because I could never...
I think that part, game mode is broken, right?
Because I feel like I just can't get that part to work.
No!
I just think that part's broken.
I did get the newest version.
I did!
Guys, I just...
But it has a second song.
I got the second song working.
Wait, it worked for you?
How did it work for you?
I have the newest version!
It's a...
Something...
It's the 0.1.1 That's the newest one.
Yeah!
I know I got the newest one because it has the third song.
That's the tomato song.
That's why I know it works.
Because it has...
It has this one.
The tomato tussling.
It has zero difficulty.
My favorite.
Look at that.
There's me.
Oh, wait.
What does that mean?
Am I tofu?
Like, what the fuck is that?
What the hell?
Oh, shit.
I'm still alive, though.
Yeah!
I can do this.
I can...
I can do this, guys.
Give me a sec.
Yeah.
It's part of the song.
If you hear a record scratch...
You won't understand.
Look at that.
Look at me go.
I'm still alive.
I'm living barely on the thread.
Oh, please.
Why?
It's so...
It's so fast.
It's so fucking fast.
Why is it so fast?
Okay.
Guys, it's obviously not zero difficulty.
It's a lie.
It's a bug, okay?
It's actually 999 difficulty.
I got this.
It's all about, like, repetition.
It's the only two skulls.
Two skulls.
I'm not looking down yet.
I assume it's still at two.
Oh, my God.
I never got this far before.
I never will.
Oh, my God.
And I'll never will, I guess.
Progress, I guess.
It's okay.
I'm figuring it out.
I know why people don't talk when they play rhythm games.
It fucks your rhythm up.
Will I learn my lesson?
Nope.
Did I...
Did I use keyboard to find sans?
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
I know it was just as hellish.
Switch to a taskpad.
It's okay.
Whoa.
I like how you guys are using my woes for the music.
It's like, no!
Where am I?
What was down scroll?
What the fuck is down scroll?
I don't even remember what down scroll was.
It's been so long.
What does down scroll do?
What does down scroll do, guys?
The secret in playing is not to think about anything.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Wee!
Yeah, that makes it easier, right?
Okay, now I can look down.
Okay.
Okay, I can do this.
That's easier, right?
I don't remember it was easier.
I don't remember.
Surely it makes it easier, right?
Oh, my keybinds, too.
It's been so long.
Wait, I think I am better.
I think I'm better with down.
I'm so dumb!
I'm so dumb.
Guys!
Guys, do you think I play better?
Okay.
Wait, I got it.
Guys, I know what to do.
I know what to do.
Okay, okay, okay.
I figured it out.
I know how to beat the system.
Okay, so...
So...
Oh, I got it!
I figured it out.
I know what to do, guys.
I'll use...
Oh, I know what to do.
I know what to do, guys.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
I know what to do.
I'm multi... I'm multi-gaming.
Okay, I already got minus 40.
I was testing it out.
Okay.
Okay, I have W, A, and Up and Down.
Surely this would be easier.
Guys, it was not easier.
Guys, it was not easy.
Oh, you're right!
Wait, wait.
Okay, wait, I got it.
Got it, I figured it out.
Oh my god, I did it!
I can fix this!
Oh my god, I'm using two hands!
Two different hands!
It works!
I'm multi-drifting!
Where am I?
It's okay, I'm still alive.
Get out!
Wait, this is the most I've been alive for!
It's okay Tomato, keep singing so I have a little more time to live!
Oh my god, I'm doing it!
Multi-drifting!
I'm alive!
Yeah!
A.S.
Upright!
I did it!
I'm multi-drifting!
I multi-drift, guys!
Look at that!
Beat the score, guys!
63,168 with zero misses!
That's right!
Zero...
Wait, give me a sec, give me a sec, guys.
Zero misses, guys!
Oh my god!
Sorry, give me a...
Zero!
Okay, there.
Look at that!
Zero misses and first try.
That's how you know I'm a gamer.
Ain't no way.
Zero misses, yep.
That's me.
Zero misses.
Thank you.
It's really hard to be such a gamer, guys.
It really is.
Okay, now let's figure out how to fucking play heist mode.
Oh, my game crashed.
Okay, so apparently I have to rename it?
How do I...
Okay, let me see.
How do I re...
Okay, I gotta rename the mod folder?
Okay, the mod folder is tomato...
I can't...
I don't know how to get the heist part working.
How do I fucking...
How do I get the heist part?
Game...
I unzip it into the mod folder.
That's literally the one thing I can't get to work.
It's just a heist.
I just need to get the heist part to work.
Yeah!
I downloaded the Google Dra...
Wait, there were more instructions?
Wait.
I had to YouTube...
I had to YouTube how to install mods.
For Friday Night Funkin'.
It was not...
Sorry, I need like...
You...
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
It was definitely not doki proof.
I...
No, this was not doki proof.
I had to watch a YouTube video.
It's in my downloads.
Okay, let's see if I can get heist here.
I renamed the folder to...
Because I actually downloaded...
Oh, I got it to work!
I renamed it properly!
Oh my God, that's me!
Oh my God!
That's you guys!
So majestic and beautiful.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, it's my like...
Song!
Guys.
Guys, give me a sec.
I did a multi-drift.
Wait.
Wait, restart.
Okay.
We're gonna watch this beautiful entry again.
I didn't like...
I didn't set up my multi-drift, guys.
My multi-drift wasn't set up yet.
Oh, I didn't bring the game sound a little bit.
Whoops.
Oh.
Okay, give me a sec.
I brought the game sound a little bit.
Okay.
There you go.
Multi-drift set up.
Okay.
That's me.
This is seven difficulty?
That's so easy!
This is easier than the tomato one!
Let's go.
That's right, be afraid.
Guys, it's still very easy.
I got this.
I think I'm hitting some things.
I don't know.
Buttons were being hit.
Here we go.
Buttons are still being...
I'm hitting stuff.
Guys, did it look like I was button mashing?
Because I was definitely not.
Look, I was hitting buttons!
It was being hit.
Okay?
Buttons were being hit.
I just didn't say what's the correct buttons or not.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
It'll be fine.
I should press the wrong button.
Okay.
I'll brute force rhythm games if I have to.
I may not be a rhythm game player, but I am.
I'm a very quick learner.
Bum-bum, bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum!
I just assume if I start bumping, maybe I'll be a better gamer.
Okay, I survived that.
I don't know how I survived that.
Oh my god!
That fight is out of... out of... how do you do that one?
That fight was freaking crazy!
I shall not see me come down yet again, my beautiful self.
I was doing it.
I was.
There's not enough time for that dumb part.
Thank you, superchat, thank you, thank you.
I'm getting better.
I'm locking in.
I'm gonna beat myself up.
Alright.
Get over here, you're nothing but a tomato.
Okay,
I'm locked in.
I'm fully locked in.
You don't get to see the right arrow key, I realize, but that's okay.
You don't need to see it.
God, how do people get like perfect score on this?
You're not really gonna be challenged, I realize.
It's okay.
Things are not looking too bad.
Okay, I'm being saved by the longer arrows.
Why is it so fast?
Fast!
I can't process it correctly!
Oh my God.
It's okay.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm figuring there's so many arrows.
There's so many fucking arrows.
It's not that easy.
Okay, I'm fully locked in.
I'm kicking my own ass.
Okay, we're figuring it out.
We got the long arrows.
My savior.
Okay, that's fine.
I have long arrows.
It's okay.
This is my savior.
Before things get rough.
It's okay, long arrows!
Saving my day yet again!
Long arrows, please come save me.
I don't know what to do.
There's so many.
How do I get out of my personal hell?
Oh, it's like Sans all over again.
What the fuck does visualize the beat even mean?
What does that mean?
This part I'm doing okay.
Now it's three scuffs instead of 20.
I don't know.
Did I use keyboard?
I don't remember how I did it.
How did I beat Sans?
I don't remember what I did.
I had like the most optimal setup keyboard setup.
Is it long boys?
Save me!
Save me, long boy!
Okay, guys, I know what to do.
I know what to do, guys.
I know what to do.
I'm gonna cheese it even more.
Okay, let me watch myself fly in again.
I know what to do, guys.
I'm swapping keys.
I'm swapping keys!
It's because they were too far.
The arrow key and the w a were too far, guys.
I gotta feel it.
I gotta be born with the rhythm.
Okay, wait.
Okay, guys, see?
It's on normal, guys.
JK, now I know I can do it.
See, guys?
How would I lose?
Guys, I swapped my keys around.
Guys, how would I lose?
Guys, it took me a while to adjust the key swaps, guys.
That's why.
It took me a while.
I forgot I swapped my keys, guys.
That's what happened.
Okay.
There we go.
Save me, long keys.
Long arrows, save me.
Okay,
long keys, save me.
Oh, God.
There we go.
Wait a minute.
Okay, guys.
Guys, I know what to do, guys.
Guys, no, no, no, no.
It might be because...
It might... Guys, guys, guys, look.
I figured it out.
Now I know what's wrong.
Guys, no, no, guys, guys, it's because, guys, I have to do story mode, guys.
Let me, let me, let me do a story mode real quick, guys, because we, let me, we gotta go with options, and then we gotta fix our controls, and then so we can, you know, so we can do, uh, what was it?
Uh, was it D, F, and J, K?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
D, uh, D, F, J, oh, J, K.
There we go.
Now, now that I figured it out, guys, now that I figured it out, I'm gonna swap my keyboard to my wooden keyboard.
Because we're about to start gaming, and I have the fastest, I set it up so it go, it go fast, and then, because now that I have my wooden keyboard, now that I have my wooden keyboard, and it's on hard, hard difficulty, we got this.
Okay, guys, I'm... It's been a while.
Guys, it's... I'm not used to new controls.
Here we go, I figured it out.
Oh my God.
Okay, I'm free.
Okay, I'm doing a lot better though.
I am doing a lot better, you gotta admit that.
On, like, hard.
I didn't mean to say that, I fucking fumbled my notes.
Okay.
No, it's fine, it's fine, I'm really good at rhythm, guys, I'm getting better.
I'm so good at rhythm.
Look at that!
Look at that, I'm beating the middle up!
That's me!
See?
So easy, a child could do it.
But not me, I'm not a child.
That's why it's even easier.
I think I found it.
I think I found my sound setup.
Mic drop.
There you go, look at that!
Don't look at the last note, but look at that!
No, no, no!
Hard difficulty is hard!
Guys, hard difficulty is hard!
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I never go easy, guys, you know me.
Me going easy?
That's crazy talk.
You might need to get your glasses checked.
You just think I'm on easy right now.
What do you mean?
Look at that!
You can tell this is very hard.
Look at how fast I'm going.
Look at me, I'm on the left side, by the way.
Can you tell I'm on the left side?
Because that's me?
I'm fighting against boyfriend.
I steal his woman.
Wait, this is actually so much easier.
Why was I playing on this keyboard?
Oh yeah, because I had no arrow keys on it.
Jesus Christ.
That's okay.
Long arrows!
My savior!
Okay.
Oh my god, I got baited.
Oh my god, you fucked me!
That could have killed me!
Guys, don't look.
Guys.
Guys, it says...
Extra hard.
Guys, don't look.
Don't look.
That's what it says.
Wow!
Oh my god!
Look at that.
Wow!
Extra hard!
Oh my god, I'm such a gamer.
Yeah, that's right.
That's me.
Extra hard.
Sorry, I was actually on a separate difficulty that only I can unlock.
Oh wait, lasso looter.
That's an extra one, right?
Oh god, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
Oh wait, what?
Oh my god.
Wait, that's me!
Yeehaw!
That's so cute!
The background's so fucking cute!
Look at me go.
Oh my god, I need to learn a new... I need a few new muscle memories.
Wait, I'm still... I'm singing with her?
I'm with me?
Long arrow, thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh, this...
It's okay, not that difficult, guys.
Nice.
Yeah!
First try!
On extra hard.
Yeah!
First try!
Let's go!
I'm curious, though.
I am...
I am curious on what regular hard difficulty is like.
Maybe it'll be even easier, you know?
On regular hard difficulty.
I mean, haha.
Let's see how that's like.
Let's see how regular hard is like.
Sorry.
I...
I saw those notes.
I didn't know what to think.
When I saw those notes.
Where am I?
Did I bug out?
Wait, but I'm still alive, though.
I think I broke the game.
Like, my mind actually buffered trying to look at it.
The camera...
The camera even was like, the fuck is this?
Where am I?
Just get me out.
Okay, alright.
But like, what is normal difficulty on?
Actually, what is normal difficulty on?
This one was very hard.
Even on very hard, it was very hard.
I'm curious.
There's me.
I'm flying.
Hello, everybody.
It's me, Doki Bird.
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's see how hard is hard.
Okay, um...
It's not that bad.
Not gonna lie.
Guys.
It's not that bad.
I can't.
I failed.
I'm dying to be the free.
I'm dying to fly again.
Guys.
My tiny tomato brain.
Might decide to retire.
But, I mean, we still have...
Alright, guys.
Look at that.
I'm such a gamer.
I finished.
Those were fun, though.
But it's not over yet, guys.
Since we still...
I wanna play more mods.
So let's do another mod.
Let's add another.
You know what?
Since I have Friday Night Funkin' out right now.
Let's check out some other mods, too.
But, yeah!
Thank you to the Dragoons!
Who made this!
I really appreciate it.
I can't wait to see the finished version in the future.
Next time I'm gonna try this out is when the finished version comes out, too.
So, yeah.
Huge shoutout to the Dragoons.
For making...
Tomato Funkin'.
That was really fun to play.
Let's see if you Dragoons can do it better.
On hard difficulty, huh?
I was on very hard, guys.
So, I don't know.
I don't know if you guys can beat what I did.
Huge shoutout to all the people that made this mod.
I had a great time checking it out.
Like I said, I've never actually played the main base game.
But I've already seen.
But, like, we don't need to play the main base game.
I think it's more fun.
I think the mods are more fun than the actual main base game.
And there's like so...
Wait, what the fuck?
There's a Simpsons mod.
There's like...
I know there's like a ton of really...
There's like a lot of really good versions where they like fucked around with like a ton of different mechanics and stuff.
There was like one I was looking at that seemed really cool.
Oh my god, there's a Miku one.
Wait, they have a Miku mod?
Of course they do.
You know what?
Of course they have a Miku mod.
It's Friday Night Funkin'.
What?
Oh my god.
They have a Spongebob mod?
Oh my...
Wait.
Wait, I want to see what are mods.
Wait, let's see.
Where am I on?
Okay, Friday Night Funkin'.
What's the most downloaded?
Of course the tricky one is the most downloaded.
What's the Psych Engine?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, there's a Doki Doki Literature Club?
Wait, there's Doki Doki Literature Club.
There's Hypnos Lullaby.
Why are they all like horror themed?
Why is there so many horror...
Oh my gosh, wait.
I forgot.
A lot of the people...
Is it really weird for me... Is it fucked up for me to say that a lot of the community here for Friday Night Funkin', like the majority...
It's like Five Nights at Freddy's are like children so like horror themed stuff is like the way to go for the kids.
It's usually like if we want the children fan base you make a horror themed mod.
Children really like...
I don't know why.
I don't know why children really, really like horror.
I don't understand.
Friday Night Funkin' mods.
Like it just feels like a lot of kids just really like just really, really like horror mods or horror games in general.
Let's see.
I'm gonna check out the Miku.
I wanna do the ones where they have like cool mechanics.
There's like ones where like they add like unique mechanics to the Friday Night Funkin' stuff.
I wonder if I can find one.
I saw like there were people posting like stuff for it too.
Oh my god, where is it?
What's in this lullaby?
Oh, that shit's scary.
This is not...
Wait, wait, I know!
Wait!
Wait, I know which one to play!
Wait, oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
I know exactly which one I wanna... I know which one I wanna do.
Wait, I...
I know which one I wanna play.
I wonder if it's this one.
Okay, wait, no, this is full.
Wait, old version?
Oh, this one.
Okay.
I know exactly which one.
New.
Okay, I'm downloading.
I'm downloading this one.
I wonder if it works.
Okay.
Download.
I downloaded it twice.
Okay guys, don't worry, guys, give me like...
I have... Oh my god, I want...
I'm so excited for this one.
Hahahaha Hahahaha You'll see.
You'll see, guys.
You'll see what it is the moment when I get... You'll see, guys.
Hahahaha It's a good one.
I swear to... It's pretty good.
I swear to god, it's a good one.
Oh my god, there's the Fall Guys version!
There's Fall Guys, there's...
Some of them are like... there's like Simpsons.
There's My Little Pony.
Okay, so there's... oh my... oh, there's my favorite one.
There's one that I really, really like.
That's like... that I'm like obsessed with in terms of the song.
Wait, what's the Among Us version?
Okay.
Where's the mods?
I'm like so confused looking at...
I'm so confused looking at like all these versions of Friday Night Funkin'.
Because there's... I've never been on Gamebanana before.
And there's just so much information that I'm like getting overloaded.
Like, I'm just like... I can't even word because there's so many texts in front of me.
There's just so many words.
Wait!
Oh my god, do they... oh, wait.
Okay, I need to see.
I need to see if they have this one.
Okay, do they have a good version of this game in particular?
No, they don't!
I'm sad.
I was trying to say they have a good Animal Crossing version of Friday Night Funkin'.
So I can like...
So I can play like K.K.
Slider songs on it.
I'm pretty scuffed.
I'm looking at it.
It's pretty scuffed.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, did I download it?
Oh my god, it's such a huge file!
It's such a fucking huge file!
Yeah, that would be cool.
Yeah, I wanted to see if they had an Animal Crossing version because I want to be K.K.
Slider.
Okay.
I'll sing Bubblegum.
There's so many horror.
I feel like every line is just another horror mod.
That's just crazy how many horror mods there are.
Load more, please.
Wait, most liked...
Actually, most viewed should be the one to look at.
Usually the most viewed would be like the best ones.
I wish they can have like most viewed and then like...
Oh wait, it can.
Most viewed...
Oh, there's not.
Like within like the last month or the last year or something.
Because usually the newer ones are also like pretty cool too.
They had like cool...
There's like the shaggy one.
Wait.
Shaggy...
Shaggy Friday.
That one looked fucking insane.
I remember watching a YouTuber play the shaggy mod.
They had it.
Is it shaggy corrupted?
Is it that one?
Where he fucking goes crazy?
Oh yeah, the seven keys.
Yeah, this...
I'm not playing.
Guys, by the way, there's no way I'm playing that version.
Because he fucking gives you seven keys.
I'm like...
Yeah, we are not finishing.
We are not beating that whatsoever.
Yeah, that's really...
Yeah, I remember seeing...
Oh wait, what's this?
Sustice Snogas.
The fuck is that?
Oh my god.
That...
This one's definitely for kids.
That was definitely made for kids.
Iden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's a mod called Mario's Madness.
It's a surprising good mod.
Has a lot of content and mechanics.
It's also one of few mods that's not cancelled by the devs.
What does that mean?
What do you mean by cancelled by the...
Oh, you mean like they're still working on it?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the super chat, Iden.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, what's this?
Mario's Madness.
Never heard of it.
Wait, is there Mario's Madness?
Mario's Madness Version 2 but ported in 6K.
What?
Where is just...
There's like Mario's Madness Version 2 but ported in 6K.
The fuck does that mean?
Is it not just the original?
Oh, Madness Origins?
Oh wait, what the fuck does that mean?
Why is there so many information?
What about Mario's Madness?
Oh, did it finish downloading?
Yeah!
Okay.
How do I do this?
Oh wait, it's its own execution too!
Okay, nice.
Extract.
I need you to extract yourself now.
Extract all.
Okay.
Nice.
It's its own EX file.
Okay.
Let's see if this works.
I hope I don't get a virus.
Let's see.
Oh my God!
That's so fucking funny!
It's its own, like, little...
Select song.
Freeplay unlocked.
But what if I don't want to freeplay?
How do I play it?
Wait, no, I don't want to join the Discord.
How do I play your song?
Do I activate it?
Oh my God, that's...
Wait.
What?
You can use power-ups?
What the fuck?
Wait.
I need to fix my opti...
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I realized I never...
I didn't fix anything.
I...
I got really confused, guys.
I got very confused.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, things should be better now.
Wait, they don't have the down.
Wait, visuals.
Wait.
Wait, they don't have scroll down.
Down scroll, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
I'm okay now.
Guys, everyone...
I'm okay now, guys.
Guys, fuck.
It keeps trying to make me join their Discord.
How do I play the game?
How do I play your game?
Stop!
I'm trying to want to join your Discord server!
It keeps...
It keeps accidentally clicking the server.
Please!
I'm telling you!
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
I got this.
Option?
Wait, no, not option.
How did I start the song before?
Oh, activate!
Oh, it's activate.
It's the green button.
It's the tiny ass green button.
Okay, I figured this out.
Alright, TF2A.
Bandicam is temporary.
Okay, I got this.
I'm a better scout.
I'm a little worried that I couldn't select difficulty.
Long arrows save the day.
Okay, my HP is still okay, guys.
I need that long arrow.
Save me.
Wait, wait, what?
No!
Oh my god!
What the fuck happened?
What did he do to me?
What do I do?
Holy shit.
Am I supposed to hit the drink?
I couldn't tell.
Oh no, don't hit the drink.
I was dodging them at first.
Because I couldn't tell.
Okay, don't hit it.
Oh my god, this is...
This is my training arc right here.
My ma trained me for this.
Oh my god!
Fuck you!
He's so good!
I'm trying so hard!
This act, there's no difficulty setting too!
That's the worst part!
That's the best part.
Oh my god, it's like Sans all over again.
No!
No, it's just like part!
Oh my god!
It's like Sans all over again!
It's just like Sans!
Please!
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm getting better though.
I think.
No!
I drank the thing!
No, I drank the thing!
I drank the drink!
I drank the...
Please, Scout, stop!
Stop!
I drank the thing.
Couldn't help it.
It was yellow.
Yellow is good, right?
I see yellow drinking.
Drink it.
Can't help it.
Oh my
god.
No, I...
Please, stop!
I keep accidentally clicking it.
I keep drinking it.
Stop!
No, dude, I can't stop myself!
Oh, French Vulture is doing things to me, chat.
That's why he's trying to steal my girlfriend.
He's finally cosplaying for me.
I'm locking in.
No!
I keep clicking on it!
It's just...
It's just there!
I just wanna drink it so badly!
I can't help it!
Please, let me get out of here.
I always get so close.
I think I'm getting worse.
And, like, he's supposed to be the easiest cos he's the first one.
This is... I can't believe it.
I can't believe it.
This is supposed to be the easiest, too.
Oh, I'm too HP!
I'm too HP!
I can't!
Oh my god!
Stop hitting it!
Stop hitting it, Doki!
Please, just get out of the first level!
That's all I ask!
Just get out of the first level!
Stop drinking!
This song's gonna be stuck...
It's gonna live right free in my head for the rest of the day.
I already forgot that I was supposed to go.
That's okay, I'm getting better at that part.
Oh,
without the long lines, I would've been so fucked.
Please have mercy on me!
Please, Scout!
Please!
Have mercy on me, Scout!
I'm sorry, you're dead, Spy!
I mean, not gonna lie, it's pretty cool.
Oh my god, it's on hard and you can't change it?!
This is Team Fortress 2.
You can't even change the...
Oh my god.
TF2 players are like, you go hard or you go home.
There's no Weenie Hut Jr. for you.
You're not in Overwatch right now.
Return my HP, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on!
I was doing so well!
I was actually...
That was my best run!
That was my best run that I've done so often!
I started mouth-breathing so often.
Oh my god.
Why does he do this to me?
It was the best run I've ever had!
Oh my god.
The fact that it only is in hard difficulty is the most messed up part.
Okay.
HP!
I couldn't!
It's just too much going on!
My HP was gone!
That was my locked-in moment.
The two ones before was my...
Oh my god.
That was my moment of shame.
I could never recover.
This song will be honey-tokey in the stream chat.
Thank you for the stream chat.
Thank you.
I'm still getting better, right?
Okay, I don't actually know if I'm getting better.
I think
I am.
Why?
Maybe I'm not hitting a thing.
Oh, I'm 7 HP, guys.
No!
I'm 7 HP!
Please!
Please, let me change it!
Team Fortress 2!
I wanna go back to Weedion Jr. Let me go to Weedion Jr.
Please let me do Weedion!
Please, Tokyo.
I'm believing less and less, guys.
Give me my HP back.
No!
Oh my god!
Please!
There has to be a way!
Please let me...
I'm so sad.
There is none.
Go big or go home.
Uncle, I'm coming.
Please.
Why is the default difficulty hard?
Okay.
I got this.
You're right.
I can't give up now.
I will beat him just like how I beat Sans.
Oh, I'm getting worse, guys.
You guys ain't looking so good for me.
I'm getting worse.
I am not locked in.
No, I hit the thing.
I hit the thing.
Guys, I hit the thing.
No!
I hit the thing!
Please.
I'm trying.
I'm trying so hard.
You don't understand.
My rhythmless brain was never supposed to put in the deep end of the swimming pool.
It's like chucking a baby out into the ocean and be like, learn to swim.
Please, I'm an FPS gamer.
Not a rhythm gamer.
Have mercy.
He's just a tomato.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm trying.
It's always the cans.
It's the cans.
It's the cans, guys.
Okay.
Okay, Toki.
Can't be that bad.
Remember when I was so happy to play TF2?
My...
Those...
Those were the good old days.
I wish I never found you.
I...
I was so happy at the beginning of the stream.
I had actual joy in my heart.
I was like, oh my god, they're scouts.
Look at how much effort they put into this mod.
There was so much joy.
Okay.
I thought...
I thought there would be difficulty settings.
There's no difficulty settings.
It's just straight into it.
Don't finish me.
Please, scout.
Just a tomato.
Let me sing, let me sing!
Why won't you let me sing?!
He just let me slowly die!
Beauty can often be a mask to evil, but I think even the super chat thinks this mod would be a pretty good example for what we've seen.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please let me sing.
Stop!
My HP!
No!
No, my regen!
My regen!
Where did my regen go?!
Where's Saxton Hell when I need him?!
Please!
Fire him!
He's bullying...
Oh, he would like that.
No, Saxton Hell would like bullying children.
He's like...
Okay.
I got this.
Yes, I'm still on this!
It's just like Sans all over again.
I was like, wow.
I have some extra time.
I finished that mod pretty quick.
Let me look at different other mods.
This music though.
No, I fucked up.
I got no regen.
I picked this hell.
I picked this...
I picked this hell for myself and I can't escape!
I can't escape!
I have to finish this to escape from my freedom!
I just can't escape this hell.
I picked this hell too, that's the worst part.
At least the song's good.
Oh
my god, I'm...
There has to be a way!
Please!
There has to be a difficulty set.
I refuse to believe that there is no diffic...
I refuse.
There has to be a...
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
I am at the free play!
There's no other contracts!
There's only one.
There's only one contract.
That's the worst part.
Wait, there is other contracts.
Oh my god, there is!
Goodbye, ScoutJK.
JK, there was other contracts.
Guys, maybe...
Maybe Pyro would be easier, guys.
Maybe Pyro...
Guys, maybe he'll be easier!
Maybe...
Guys, maybe there's freedom.
Who the fuck is this guy?
Who is he?
It's a shorter song.
I don't remember this guy.
A civilian?
Oh, I can get money?
What does the money do for me?
Oh shit.
I'm gonna get money?
What does the money do?
I'm gonna get money.
That was so close!
On my first try!
Oh my god, it was so close.
Oh my god, I was right there.
That was so good for a first try.
I was so locked in.
I was breathing through my mouth.
Everything was going so well.
I was like, this is it.
This is the first time I beat any of their fucking contracts.
This is gonna be it.
I was gonna fucking make a name for myself right here.
Alright.
The money.
I don't have long notes to save me to when I fuck up.
I don't know what the money does.
Oh no, it's the fun part!
I fell for it again!
I fell for it.
Let's try this one.
Maybe he won't BS me.
Spy, you won't be that fucked up, right Spy?
Surely not.
The most backstabbing character won't fuck me over like that, right?
What do you mean this one is worse?
What do you mean by that?
Oh my god, maybe Scout was the easiest.
Wait,
Miss Pauling!
She won't fuck me over.
She's so...
Oh no, she's not nice.
Yeah!
Hello, Miss Pauling!
Oh, I'm on the left side?
Oh my god, I'm not used to being on the left side.
It's like Tekken all over again.
Or Street Fighter.
Miss Pauling won't be so fucked up, right?
You're so nice to me.
Wait, no.
Demo, what are you doing here?
Demo, get out of here!
Demo, no!
No!
Get out of here!
Demo!
No!
Oh no.
I still have a minute of Demoman.
Guys, this is not looking too good for me.
Which one is me?
But that was so cheap!
I couldn't tell which one was me.
I thought that was just gonna fit in.
It was gonna fit in.
Oh my god.
Demoman!
I was five seconds away!
Oh my god.
This is a banger song.
Oh my god, I feel so messed up right now.
After this whole switcheroo.
The switcheroo is fucking me up.
Oh, sense of security.
This is the entire game.
Don't ever say I didn't do hard mode.
Succeeding is a different story, but I'm trying my best.
This is the hardest one I've ever played.
The hardest Friday Night Funkin' mod I've ever done.
As a non-rhythm gamer, please, this is a lot for me.
As a non-rhythm gamer, this is a lot.
Oh my god, Demo, get out.
Get out, Demo, get out!
Leave!
This is my home.
This is my home now!
This is fucking me up, guys.
No!
Oh my god.
Why are they all like this?
Maybe, guys...
Maybe, maybe, guys...
Maybe he's easier.
Maybe...
We'll find the easiest one.
Demo, it's you again.
Get out!
Not that bad.
I got the last.
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
It's so bad.
Guys, guys...
There's still one more.
We still have one more.
We still have...
Soldier.
We still have soldier.
He can't...
He's illiterate.
What the fuck is...
What?
Why is the animation different?
What's going on?
Is this like a guest animator?
What?
Who am I?
Am I playing as Soldier or Engie?
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell which one I was playing.
Oh, I broke it.
Guys, I broke the game.
I broke the cutscene.
Oh, there we go.
I was like...
What is this?
I've never seen this one before.
Team Fabulous 2?
I've never seen that.
I need more HP.
Why is there no...
Difficulty setting?
No!
This game won.
This game beat me.
I can't...
The close...
Okay.
I'll do one more attempt.
The closest I've ever been...
Was Miss Pauling.
She was the closest.
She was the closest I've ever been.
She was...
No, I never got close to Scout.
Miss Pauling, at least...
At least I got five seconds left.
She was the closest to victory I've ever had.
I miss Miss...
Oh my god.
When I look at Miss Pauling versus everybody else, it's so slow.
Compare...
And then I get to Demoman.
She's so slow compared to everybody.
I miss that.
I miss that so much.
Okay.
She's just chill like that.
I told you, she's so nice to me.
And then the fucking Demon shows up.
Fucking Scotsman.
Get out!
Leave!
You stupid Cyclops!
No, please.
No!
The shift!
The shift threw me off!
The shift.
Whenever he shifts, I don't know what to do.
When it shifts, I get confused.
I get so confused.
Everything goes so fast.
Kill me first, I guess.
Get me out of this Friday Night Funkin'.
Oh my god.
Why can't everybody be just like you, Miss Pauling?
Why can't they be just like you?
And the music is so chill, guys.
I'm definitely feeling the feeling of chill right now.
That pussy.
He's here to fuck me up.
He's here.
Oh my god,
I already took up most of my HP.
Every time I don't have 10, I actually start with 10 HP.
No!
I'm not strong enough.
Guys, I can't.
Guys.
One last.
One last attempt, guys.
Guys.
I'm sort of on a time limit.
Because I'm going to a cat cafe at 8 PM.
I just wanted to pet some cats.
I wanted to go outside and touch some cats.
Okay.
Okay,
it does lose my HP more.
I was going to say, what if I just start spamming?
And then I fucked up.
What the fuck?
Have they been saying really fucked up shit at the bottom left?
I just noticed.
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
I did it.
Oh my god!
No wonder it's so hard.
This is like Team Fortress 2 all over again.
Just a standard TF2 experience.
Okay, guys, I'm just going to pretend I didn't see it.
TF2 is back, baby.
No wonder they don't even have...
They don't even have a difficulty slider for me.
Goodbye.
I'll do this again next week.
I'll complete one level next week.
I can't.
I have an appointment with some kitty cats.
Next week.
I thought this would be a fun little mod to play to kill some time.
I thought.
I'll post pictures of the cats.
Okay, guys, I promise I'll post the pictures of the cats later.
I promise you guys that.
I'll post the pictures of the cats, guys.
I promise.
On Twitter.
But for now, I can't.
I don't...
I wanted to relax after the stream.
And I was like, I've never been to the cat cafe.
I've actually never been to a cat cafe before.
Isn't that crazy?
Not even like in Japan have I went to.
I went to like the hedgehog cafe and the pig cafe in Japan.
But I've never been to a cat cafe.
And I was like, wait, there's like one.
There's like...
They opened a new one.
And so I wanted to check it out.
Because I was like, you know what?
Let's bug it.
Let's try it.
Let's check out this cat cafe.
And it's like appointment only.
So I was just like, okay.
Alright, I'll do it like after my stream.
And I didn't realize this would take up my entire day.
Fucking Team Fortress 2.
I was like, Team Fortress 2.
Anyway.
I'm gonna fucking.
I'll finish one level next week.
Next week, I'll come back and finish one level, guys.
It was fun though.
I need my cat therapy.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, it's a fact.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.